how are things in philly right now
[Music]
philly cheesesteak with mushroom and
onions
like this little village field
[Music]
and 14 presidents have been pre-med
a secretary of handshake
frankly
[Music]
good afternoon guys philadelphia the
birthplace
of american democracy and
quite honestly a very uh impressive
surprisingly beautiful place it's my
second day here
today i want to show you the streets the
buildings
talk to some people eat some food i love
it
i think you'll love it too let's do this
[Music]
all right guys before we get into the
street life
i want to bring you in a couple
buildings here uh the first is ritz
carlton looks like something out of
grease
here we go
philadelphia home to many firsts first
library
hospital med school uh national
first national capital stock exchange
zoo and business
school
i believe this is called the french
quarter
some classic beauties art deco
if you're an art deco freak you'll like
this city
here's one of these classic art deco
entryways how you doing
i was here yesterday you remember me is
it cool if i
take some photography check out these
old school old school
elevators these lights
lighting above on the ceiling and then
you got this
colors changing
beautiful walls floor thank you
you see how this was once a rotary door
i haven't been to chicago for a long
time but i'm gonna say
the architecture here might be second to
new york
in the country uh just the collection
the different styles you got this art
deco beauty
you got this modern high rise behind it
and then just all this detail here and
then little boutique
style stuff tree-lined streets
it's quite pleasant i gotta say
[Music]
and this is you know the thing i love
about europe is
well you get the beautiful architecture
and you can walk the streets in there
they're stimulating to the eye and i
feel that here
but we're at a mid-october
and the weather is absolutely perfect so
we got a lot of this during the coveted
times obviously
dining outside i'd say people on the
streets here
are very strict with the mask most
people are fully up
it's hard to talk with this uh so when
not around people
like close i bring it down
but it's interesting to see right now in
america what states
well how states are different with masks
and uh handling the covet i believe it's
25
open inside and then it looks like full
dining on the outside
so usually the first day in a city is
you don't really have your bearings the
second day you get a little more of the
feel
and then you know in time you start to
really understand it so i'm at that
point where it's day two
and uh it feels different than any city
i've been to
it's definitely not new york it doesn't
have that
pulse of new york uh which is cool
in its own right it's it's more of a
condensed
user-friendly version i'd say you were
in the philippines and hong kong
yeah yeah so bay
it's a military it was a base
it was the naval base
the more i traveled the world the more i
realized
at least 50 of what i say i
uh think differently
could be even weeks after maybe months
after maybe years after but
i was just in ukraine a few weeks ago
and i was saying hey in ukraine they
have these parks where everyone sort of
chills and america is too busy
uh nobody's really ever doing that and
now i'm here
and uh well that's not the truth very
cool relaxed vibe in here
philadelphia has some rough parts
but these are not them you guys are
doing a great job here
on the street i don't know it looks
beautiful oh thank you somebody needs to
say to me
no it looks the colors the blue just
bounces pops
very nice yeah i've been doing this for
35 years
35 years yep you from philly yeah
[Music]
windows now okay
how are how are things in philly right
now
pretty cool uh people were going about
their way
it's a little much much quieter than it
was
yeah when were the riots couple months
ago yeah they were back in uh
april april may someone's around there
was that scary stuff
they didn't bother me now they were just
doing their thing they
they weren't bothering any people this
expression where they felt that's all
take care
most of the houses are no foreign
so the woman there was saying most of
these are single families
but we are very close to the center of
the city and it's got like this little
village feel to it you can see their
financial center
so it's a very good mixture of this
this quiet atmosphere and then
busy city
oh look at that one that's so beautiful
that's beautiful
[Music]
what's the name of this neighborhood
this is on queens village
queens village what's it known for like
funky shops and that sort of thing
yeah it changes at night it gets a
little
more ghetto okay but now it's cool yeah
now it's cold
you'll see that that's why they have all
their clothes off the streets everybody
comes down with their motorcycles
oh yeah the razer ruckus
but they're super cool neighborhoods all
written house is really good
thank you bro thank you
all right here we go jim stakes this is
uh
from what i've understood a staple a
classic
some of the best philly cheesesteak in
the city
maybe a bit touristy i'm not sure but
look at the design this is cool
this is art deco style
here we got our philly cheesesteak
master loading up the bun
all the fixings cheese
she's got the meat cooking there all
chopped up
onions on the other side pressing the
bread
getting the cheese hot onions in
folding over
what's up man i'll do a mushroom philly
cheese steak with mushroom and onions
i saw you yesterday was [ __ ] amazing
dude that's
really good
steaming meat mushrooms onions
and a very soft hoagie roll
so good
little bit everything in here tattoo
shop middle eastern cuisine
what's this burgers good i love blocks
like this where you get about
20 30 different businesses right on top
of each other
from every industry you can think of
there's a haircutting place
crash bang boom don't know what that is
boutique uh i just wanted to update you
about a couple of streams
interesting thing about american cities
is quite often
you have a street like this which is a
cool interesting street but at night the
taxi
driver said it's a little bit skittish a
little bit sketchy
and then literally one block over
can be a completely different world so
i'm going to fast forward this and
you'll see what i'm talking about
and here you go totally different world
i'm sure this is very expensive real
estate
beautiful town homes
here we have independence hall that's
where the declaration of independence
and the constitution were both signed to
the right here
right there i think it is the liberty
bell
the symbol for democracy and freedom in
america and then off in the distance
national constitution center so if
you're looking for museums
history there are a ton of museums here
it would take weeks really to
explore all these places city hall
financial district and this is a free
mason's
lodge we're gonna go inside here
there's a tour you can take i don't know
much about
the freemasons actually pretty much
nothing all i do know is i see those
signs
in many towns in america many cities
many many places in the world
some what of a secretive society
fraternity and there's all sorts of
conspiracies about the freemasons
i'm gonna meet my wife she's
gonna meet me on the tour
here we go masonic temple freemason
lodge
this is so beautiful
you'll actually go into those different
rooms and see them so
okay awesome thank you
it's not a religion each state has their
own grand lodge
okay and each state runs their own
masonic program
this room is called oriental hall we're
going to have the worshipful master
the secretary to take minutes the
treasurer
to tell us that we forgot to pay our
dues all the time
and then his junior warden
senior wharton behind you it was
the freeman we take our
traditions from the up what we call the
operative stone basins
operative meaning they were the ones who
actually had the hammer and chisel and
they were cutting stones
when the masons come in for their
meetings they might just go straight to
their lounge room or
they often come in here and they sit and
they chat before they go up to their
lodge room
all those packings 23 karat gold yeah
all that that's 23 karat gold leash
it's not gold paint the portraits of the
men hanging in this room
on the wall are living past grand
masters
grand masters are in charge of the
state's masonic program for a period of
two years in pennsylvania
solid bronze one time how long did he
say
it took them to paint this 34 years
guys i think it was 34 years to paint
this whole place
okay we're up before anyone else
and uh i gotta say the feeling here
there's a very powerful feeling do you
feel that love
like a very intense
grounded feeling yeah i have no idea
what goes on in here
it's your idea we're gonna do two year
tour
uh terms i just wanna say two party
military
two-year terms uh-huh so they only do
two-year terms okay
and do they get voted in yeah okay it's
kind of
technically yes uh-huh but it's kind of
a thing just like in the lodges where
you move up is kind of the thing where
they're in their
grand lodge position they kind of move
up and 14
presidents have been freemasons
i can't name them all it goes all the
way down and the counterbalance
is underneath that wall any profession
can join
any profession can join you
my huge estrada freemasonry was the
symbology and the mystery behind it and
yeah i mean i'm sure you're looking
around but
you'll notice these symbols
down there whoa
whoa
[Music]
yes this is egyptian hall wow
now this we have had archaeologists
and egyptologists come in this room and
they have looked at this is
unbelievable guys
downtown philadelphia and they looked at
the hieroglyphics
and the paintings are accurate
and the hieroglyphics
many different symbols up here janus
symbol
i saw the star of david somewhere two
things they can't talk about religion
or politics
as you look around you can see what
looks like a lot of celtic
nuts at least the celtic influence
in the painting on the walls but then if
you look up
you see the wood cross beams and then
these four panes down along here
they represent the four cardinal virtues
of temperance
fortitude prudence and justice
this is copied from various churches and
cathedrals that were built
in italy during the renaissance building
period
we did copy this from different churches
and cathedrals
sistine chapel so they're in there as
perfect copies but we leave them blank
because again freemasonry is not a
religion
we don't practice any religion here
this room is built to resemble an
outdoor greek amphitheater
the most popular thing that happens here
is a wedding
you do not have to be a freemason or
have any masonic ties to have a wedding
here
you haven't heard of our abaddon yet
you can have a wedding here what funds
all of the freemasons right now as a
member you have to pay dues yeah
we fund ourselves a lot of big name
donors
okay we have a lot of people who when
they pass they leave us
large sums of money and we have
investors
and that's what pays our bills
and we supplement with weddings and
other things it was quite eye-opening
wow that was so amazing all the uh
symbology all the extra astrological
everything
just amazing so beautiful wow
it's like you go into another world or
something that was totally another world
yeah
all right definitely got to uh learn
more about that
he said you might be like
some high up level businessman you can't
be a president
right but you come in that door and
you're sort of on the same
on the same level but there is another
hierarchy
yeah the thing i'd like to mention
though because it is sort of a closed
group like i knew nothing about
freemasons
i still don't know that much uh but
there was a good energy in there
everyone was cool to talk to you know
everyone was
well spoken and interesting and like a
good vibe
yeah but they also seem interested yes
yes they ask you questions they want to
hear your opinion
it's really interesting i want to look
into that more yeah this is not a
promotion
freemasonry but it's just a curious mind
going into something that
well i didn't know anything about and is
often misrepresented
i think it's misrepresented because they
have all this all uh
symbology right like yeah star of david
is everywhere
you see the swastika and all these
symbols existed before
they turn into something else yes this
is cool it's close and they have some
secrets they still have some uh
secretive handshakes or something that
they keep only
within the members and maybe that
secrets
you know either spike the curiosity or
they maybe scare people a little bit
that's why they create all this
conspiracy theories
i think harvest weekends
got a cafe here
cool little zone in the center of the
city
[Music]
so
[Music]
here's the famous rocky statue
we're gonna go up on the stairs those
are the stairs in the movie
rocky stairs philadelphia museum of art
one of the most famous museums
in the country and i think the world
also
what a discovery philadelphia
it was a surprise to me and always cool
to get that in your home country
when you least expect it all right guys
until next one
[Music]
thank you
you